more about waco all weekend here on
american history tv
uh
bringing these tanks and stuff around
here i tell you what being an american
first
i'm the kind of guy
that i'll stand in front of a tank you
can run over me
but i'll be back in one of the tracks no
one's gonna hurt me or my family that's
that's that's american policy here
you could have arrested me any day as i
jog up and down this road you could have
arrested me going to town or going to
walmart
waco was going to bear witness against
the atf
and i do not appreciate it and never
will i ever appreciate somebody coming
here with two
helicopters and cattle cattle trailers
and all that
and uh pushing people around guns say
i'll meet you at the doorstep any day
you know and somebody will get hurt if
you want to keep playing that game
i'm talking to you
somebody's going to get hurt
david individuals inside the branch
davidian compound exit the compound now
submit to the proper authority david
david you have had your 15 minutes of
fame it's time to leave the building
in 1992 the bureau of alcohol tobacco
and firearms began investigating a group
outside of waco texas known as the
branch davidians it was believed that
the group was making illegal
modifications to firearms and were
stockpiling the weapons
there had also been accusations of child
abuse brought against the group's leader
david koresh
the atf attempted to execute a search
warrant at the group's compound on
sunday morning february 28 1993
a gun battle broke out between atf
agents and members of the branch
davidians inside four agents were killed
during the shootout another 16 were
injured five branch davidians were also
killed and david koresh was wounded
what followed was a 51-day standoff
between federal agents and the davidians
the siege finally ended on april 19 1993
when the fbi under orders from attorney
general janet reno tried to gas the
members out of the building
fire broke out and spread throughout
killing 76 people inside including david
koresh
the
beginnings are with a fellow by the name
of victor hoddish
he was bulgarian and therefore he would
have been of the orthodox church but he
immigrated
to illinois and
there he
visited
a service of the seventh-day adventist
church which emphasized it's its basic
ideas the return of christ the advent or
the second advent second coming of
christ
and
he was convinced by their teaching so he
left his original denomination became a
seventh-day adventist
and he
began to write his own literature and he
began to critique
the parent seventh-day adventist church
thinking they
were not really
conforming to the teachings of the
church that they had relaxed a lot and
so he wanted to reform the church
and
so in the end the church rejected his
proposals for reform and basically
kicked him out of the church so he
started looking for another place to go
and
sent out scouts and
finally decided on this area near waco
texas hadith was seen as a kind of a
divine figure like an elijah
or
like a john the baptist to announce the
coming of the new kingdom so
in this tradition of the davidians
you have the notion of the importance
not only of scripture
as an authority but of a prophet and
recognizing what a prophet
um can do for the community and his his
idea was it's like taking a scroll and
unrolling it and you find new
information uh that you can read as you
go along and he said the prophet does
that and so i'm giving new insights
uh to you so this this is why then
other people will follow him so in 55 um
a fellow by the name of ben rhoden
who was familiar with and had been with
this teaching of of haudith
uh and had been with them
from time to time returned and said you
all are looking for a sign i'm the sign
i have
yet more information another message for
you and his idea
was that uh
to call this new movement uh the branch
what had been revealed to him was that
the the name
uh
of this leader should be the branch and
of this movement so this is where we get
the the branch davidians added on
he lived until 78 but meanwhile his wife
lois
also had a special teaching so when her
husband died
the followers just moved to her to to
lead them
um and then she uh
lived another
um
six eight years after that so she had
some
some influence until 86 is when she died
but when vernon howell
appeared
on the scene in 1980 81
very soon people began to look to him
and
he i think was considered the leader of
the movement by
83-84
so even before she was out of the
picture people began to be drawn to him
by virtue of his ability to
quote the bible string passages together
consider himself
a second messiah lamb of god or using
language such as that maybe god is the
one maybe not for sure but maybe god is
the one that's indicted a good manner
god speaks of the things he has made
revelation says god is a what
oh
david koresh came here or vernon howell
who's changed his name to david koresh
came here in 1981
and um
he started
you know basically saying that he had a
message and that god showed him things
and such lois studied with them and
it developed into a
to a point where
lois
called saul in 1984 in april of 1984 to
come to mount carmel
and to
listen to what
vernon howell at that time had to say
and to see if he was going to be the
next spiritual leader
oh isaiah talked about a ravenous bird
from the east
a person
his name is koresh according to
scripture
some theology majors say well ancient
claresh which is english cyrus was a
persian king
but the mystery is is that
the ancient cyrus's name was cyrus
but in isaiah 45 that cyrus his surname
is cyrus which is the last name
revelation says he has a new name his
name that no one knows but himself his
name is the word of god
you have to look at a lot of things to
catch the full picture
now he believed that he came to bring
judgment
on the church
and that he did because we had to judge
between truth and error
and whether we
should follow him or we should follow
the holy spirit
and uh unfortunately or
it was prophesied that it would happen
that he was going to lead the leaders or
the church into apostasy so that meant
that the leaders the
elders
which represent the church
would have to go along with them and
they did
and
they even rejected lois as the spiritual
leader
now she died two years later
so it allowed him to really take uh hold
[Music]
it's not against laws by a firearm it's
not against law
to buy anything that they sell at a gun
show
and when this is all resolved
you know
a yellow sheet is legal
the accusation is not
um
the question of collection of firearms
there
is is much debated that was the basis as
i understand it for the the warrant for
the arrest and and so forth
but um
to read the davidians many of them even
the leadership positions said that they
didn't know that that was going on or
what little they did know about it they
said was being used for
a way to make money uh just to you know
to go to a gun show and
and
sell these for profit
so that but uh using that as a uh
a method of of making
money
you know cause some eyebrows to be
raised i'm sure because
if you're coming from a
uh basically pacifist or a conscientious
objection tradition
to uh that well
then
then the claim obviously is well it's
just to make money we weren't there to
um
to do battle with anybody so forth so
that was uh
that was a difference then uh koresh's
theology
he argued that he was supposed to
sire the 24 elders
that are mentioned in the book of
revelation to be the
there at the last judgment and so forth
and to do that uh he
said that he would
cohabit with the wives of the men who
were there the married
couples and so forth so this was a huge
transition as well the question is
what am i doing
what am i doing with all these children
you know what's really going on here
well you know
god is god and this nation is supposed
to
honor and serve god it says in god we
trust on our currency
and these children that i have are for a
reason
and unless we really have the ear
and the eyes to open ourselves up to be
able to read really read the scriptures
and understand the prophecies in a lot
of the seven seals
the explanation would seem almost
foolish
so
there again this this would be um
you know contrary to what victor hoduff
had said certainly in terms of uh you
know we
we want to live
holy lives and we want to be separate
from the world and so forth so this
looks like a really a sea change in
terms of this individual and his
influence but
on the other hand
the the davidians will you know say some
of them will say well
if this was what he saw as the will of
god it was time
to have these
children born and who better to do that
than the messiah or the representative
of god
then they you know they have their
rationale but i think most outsiders
would pretty severely question that
david individuals inside the branch
davidian compound
we are in the process of placing tear
gas into the building
exit the compound now
submit to the proper authority david
[Music]
during the seeds the fbi
came to me
and they asked me if i knew
you know karesh and i told him yes i did
so i told him i can go in there and
defuse the situation i can tell karesh
that he's brought the attention of the
world
he's done
what he was called to do
and
to come out
and he'd be better off to come out alive
and teach the truth
then you know
come out dead
but the prophecy said he would die
so
they said no we can't let you go there
we've got negotiators and so on and so
forth and i said okay
[Music]
madam attorney general i am extremely
disappointed
in the decisions that have been made out
of the department of justice
the federal bureau of
investigation the
agency of alcohol tobacco and firearms
now when in god's name is the law
enforcement at the federal level
going to understand that these
are very sensitive
events
that you can't
put barbed wire
guns
fbi
secret service around them
send in sound 24 hours a day at night
and then wonder
why they do something unstable
nothing we do now can change the
suffering felt by the families of the
atf agents
or the families of those who perished in
the compound
we must do everything we can
to learn from these events
about what we can do in the future
to prevent people like david korish or
people motivated by other
thoughts from causing such a senseless
horrible loss of human life i think that
this this was a
you know a learning experience as well i
think
we've had
a lot of care in handling
little groups
since that time and i don't
i would hope that both sides have
learned something from from all of that
and
the constitution says that that we
should make no laws establishing
religion nor preventing the free
exercise of religion so here are little
groups that want to
exercise this freedom to pursue
their understanding and they're living
out of christianity as they feel is
appropriate and i think
generally the
the nation has
supported that
it's when you move from your belief
system into some practices that are seen
to be
dangerous to others or harmful in some
way
that
you might expect government intervention
so